I love coffee like I am obsessed with
coffee on average I would drink about
four to five cups a day I'm a true man
of dunya doughnuts who is the only
winner right here
Duncan is my jam okay Starbucks tastes
like a homeless man's toe whoo this hot
water sure is nice so what I love it
that is water that's someone just like
Pete energy water water II to the point
that I don't know if I'm here BuzzFeed
or whitewater rafting nope nope see you
know when you drink it okay I like to
imagine myself on a on a porch uh in
Maine
and then just sodas it that's it and if
you feel good look at that picture no it
doesn't okay that is also non distinct
yeah um I'm right back on that waterfall
do you have cream with your coffee every
morning cuz I'm wondering if this is
just how coffee tastes without cream and
sugar in it um like water and dirt I
like this one yeah this one's nice this
is definitely sweeter there's notes of
vanilla
it's very woodsy yeah woodsy and watery
a string through a wood I like it it's
smooth and it's delicious it is rich but
it's not too much yeah I hate when
coffee just smacks you in the face don't
wake it Oh mate this practice not really
what we was talking about oh man
I took too big of a goal easy I don't
even need to drink it it's tart - oh
yeah thank you
oh that already has a little more bite a
little more it's like the whiskey of
coffee this is pretty strong I think
that is just hot whiskey like I keep
drinking it I know it's addictive oh
this is Duncan yeah it does smell like
New England oh my god Duncan done I know
a New England smells like cuz I was I
was born in New England
I describe this black roof I didn't
describe something so utterly boring and
watered-down
there's complexity yeah I think there's
like total complexity in this little cup
I guess if you do that it tastes good
well they all suck this is really bad I
don't know it's like in the middle it's
like it's like flat like dark you know I
mean ma'am this one's our favorite yeah
new tool yeah okay go Starbucks good job
Starbucks that is so distinctly above
everything else on the lineup Starbucks
oh my god I'm so against big business no
basic Cheers
ah that's McDonald's are you kidding me
no way I feel like a Dunkin Dunkin Danny
McDonald what is this Dunkin that's this
thing no it's not oh that's so sorry
Wow